[Música]
llevo años queriendo estar en este
círculo rojo y ahora me quiero ir
soy maestro
hasta luego
soy maestro sí lo sé me pidieron un 5 en
magisterio
y tengo muchas vacaciones
soy maestro de infantil también lo sé me
encanta recortar pintar y colorear
recuerda pinta y colorea
y encima chico
tendrá titulación se han preguntado
muchas veces
digamos que lo tenía desde pequeño lo
tenía bastante claro que era lo que yo
quería ser en la vida dedicarme a la
docencia
en el poder salir del círculo
pero en el instituto realmente más que
orientarme me desorientaron
pero me decían que bueno pues sabía que
como ibas a estudiar magisterio que
había mucha gente que luego las el tema
de las oposiciones y si no pues es luego
es muy difícil encontrar trabajo también
por otros medios
y me decían que me fuera por ingeniería
tenía la suerte de que se me daban bien
las matemáticas y la física
entonces bueno pues decidí irme por
ingeniería evidentemente estaba claro
años después decidí dejarlo todo y
dedicarme a lo que yo quería ser mis
padres me preguntaron
que se estaba seguro de la decisión y
que por qué lo hacía y evidentemente yo
les dije que yo lo que quería es ser
feliz
y poder comer de aquello de lo que a mí
me gustará y dedicarme a cosas
levantarme cada mañana y no pensar que
tengo que ir a trabajar
poco después de terminar la carrera tuve
mucha suerte y encontré trabajo
encontré trabajo después de hacer
tantísimas programaciones tantísima
burocracia tener a los niños sentados
tan chiquitines durante tanto tiempo
en sus sillas escuchándome
la gran mayoría la gran mayoría de las
veces en silencio
obsesionando me con que tenían que
empezar a leer y escribir cuanto antes
me di cuenta o más bien ellos y ellas
hicieron que me diera cuenta de lo que
estaba haciendo
y realmente lo que estaba haciendo es
que mis alumnos y mis alumnas fueran
como yo quería que fueran sin respetar
su personalidad su originalidad y tratar
a cada ser de manera individual
se me viene a la cabeza la frase tan
famosa frase del principito de que todos
todos hemos sido niños alguna vez siendo
adultos
pero que muy pocos lo recordamos
y realmente
tuve que convertirme en niño
para que mis niños fueran niños
me emociono
ya no solo eso
ya no sólo eso sino que me di cuenta que
lo que tenía que hacer además me puse a
estudiar e investigar mucho
y encontré esa palabra que tanto amo que
es la creatividad muy escuchada y muy
conocida ya últimamente
y tenía que desarrollar ese pensamiento
creativo para no crear esos productos
homogéneos de fábrica que es lo que
hemos estado acostumbrados a hacer
por lo tanto pues un día me quise
innovar en educación ante la palabra
innovar y decidí darles un folio en
blanco
estaba con mi tutor y a los zorritos
y a cada uno de los 27 niños y a cada
uno de los 27 niños de 3 añitos y medio
les dio un folio en blanco
tenían sus colores encima de la mesa que
estaban preparados para dibujar y
solamente una orden
dibujar lo que queráis
para mi sorpresa el 50% aproximadamente
de esos chorritos no sabían que dibujar
empezaron a hacerme muchas preguntas
como por ejemplo profe puedo dibujar a
mi madre
raúl puedo dibujar
lo que sea
caldito puedo dibujar o utilizar el
color negro evidentemente el color negro
y todos los colores porque una vaca
poder ser de colores
[Música]
y de ahí fue cuando dije hay algo que en
la sociedad no estamos haciendo bien
está normalizada y como queremos que
hagan las cosas
evidentemente
después de esta actividad abierta
flexible
como yo lo llamo espacio de libertad
a medida que se fueron repitiendo este
tipo de actividades
las preguntas fueron otras y las
preguntas se dan
acorde con la curiosidad que ellos iban
teniendo
en el 2006 el parte de la creatividad
ken robinson decía que las escuelas
matan la creatividad
fue ha sido según los datos la charla de
más vista a lo largo de la historia con
millones de visualizaciones y en más de
150 países seguramente se empieza y ya
está
pero bueno mi granito de arena pondré
después yo no solamente medio enfoque en
las escuelas sino como a nivel de
sociedad sino todos los adultos que van
que rodeamos a los niños ya las niñas
después de estar investigando y leyendo
durante muchísimo tiempo las mejores
investigaciones y los mejores
investigadores y científicos que se
dedican a la creatividad he llegado a
una conclusión y es que la creatividad
es un estilo de vida
impone es un estilo de vida
digamos que
un niño cuando es pequeño bebé quiere
empezar a hablar y aún no mantiene el
equilibrio quiere la cuchara
cuando le vamos a dar de comer y quiere
tocar la quiere manipularla quiere
utilizarla quiere saber qué es y
nosotros se la quitamos cuando son más
mayores quieren atarse los cordones de
los zapatos elegir esa camiseta que
tanto le gusta y no no les dejamos por
tiempo no o por qué tenemos miedo a que
rompan las cosas en definitiva siempre
interrumpe el adulto
incluso utilizar es así además de
colores tan bonitas que hay ahora así
muy exóticas ellas que estos traigo una
pero he decidido hacerme una coleta
todas estas actividades cotidianas lo
que hace es desarrollar las funciones
ejecutivas sobre todo
la flexibilidad cognitiva la
flexibilidad cognitiva es lo que nos
permite digamos utilizar esas
estrategias que tenemos que tenemos
adquiridas para salvar algún obstáculo
no sobre todo para
salvar esos errores que vamos
convirtiendo a lo largo de la vida esas
estrategias para salvar esos errores
para ser más creativos celina álvarez es
una profesora es una investigadora
francesa que en su último libro las lee
en las leyes naturales del niño lo que
expone un estudio científico de martí
rosmán que dice que en el centenar de
niños ellos investigaron que bueno fue
un estudio longitudinal pues empezó con
3 años con 10 con 16 y con 25 llegó a la
conclusión de que esos niños que habían
que habían estado presentes en todas
estas acciones cotidianas no en la vida
diaria
habían venido
cuando fueron adultos eran más
resolutivos eran más pseudo controlaban
mejor
aparte eran más
como decía a celina álvarez es una
profesora investigadora francesa que se
ha dedicado en los últimos años a
estudiar las leyes naturales del niño en
su último libro publicado en este libro
aparece ese estudio longitudinal
cortesía de martín rose man esta mujer
científica
cogió a un centenar de niños e hizo ese
estudio longitudinal a diferentes edades
cuando llegaron a 25 años los niños que
habían participado en esas acciones
cotidianas no en esas en esas
actividades que nosotros normalmente a
los niños no les dejamos hacer
realmente los niños más resolutivo serán
más organizados
digamos que tenían más confianza en
ellos mismos muy importante y aparte
habían desarrollado más creatividad lo
cual estaba ligado que habían tenido
mayor rendimiento académico y se había
desenvuelto mejor a lo largo de su
adolescencia
después de varios años como maestro
infantil yo llegue también a una
conclusión también muy innovadora y es
que los niños aprenden jugando
innovación verdad
que un niño juegue
madre mía soy lo más total que bueno ya
lo venían diciendo hubo un movimiento
que se llama la escuela nueva a finales
del siglo 19 tenemos amigos que había ya
quien sea maestro o maestra seguramente
los conozca
y siempre decían que el juego era una
necesidad del niño 10.000 libros siempre
digo que el juego es el motor de
aprendizaje de ellos
ya no solo porque desarrollan
habilidades sociales porque enseñan y
aprenden perdón a respetar a los
compañeros aprenden a tomar decisiones a
desarrollar ese pensamiento crítico ya
desarrollar ese pensamiento reflexivo y
aparte porque en el juego quieren ser lo
que quieran ser sería otro espacio de
libertad lo que llamamos en el mundo de
la docencia el juego simbólico cuando
empiezan con las cocinitas si no se
quería imitar a los a sus padres o al
profesor no digamos a esas personas que
les rodean de forma más cercana a aquel
que le llama la atención y se convirtió
en el astronauta lo que un día que dejé
me fui antes al colegio dejé la clase
diáfanas quité todas las mesas las
sillas
puse papel continuo en el suelo y nos
disponíamos a pintar con tempera
simplemente a manchar nos estaba con mi
clase de los caballitos de mar
maravillosas
empezamos mientras yo me estaba
manchando las manos de tempera
evidentemente estaba observando como
cada uno y cada una de ellas
se comportaba cuáles eran sus conductas
y que no me faltará ninguno eran también
28 niños
y así echarles un ojo
me faltaba que si fulanito de la mesa
roja menganito del equipo azul en
definitiva como cuatro o cinco niños
yo pensé iluso de mí pues se habrán ido
al baño y se estarán limpiando porque se
hayan cansado de estar pintando con
témpera me voy así como shakira muy
sigiloso al pasar
y miro por una ventana que tenía en el
baño
y estaban jugando
madre mía jugando
para que me ponga en la puerta así de
modo jarritas digo a ver
qué pasa aquí
y se gira uno me mira yo le miro
nos miramos fijamente
y así entre emoción y nervioso como
diciendo me han pillado con la cara
llena de tempera verde los brazos las
manos todos llenos de tempera verde y me
dice profe
soy hull
[Aplausos]
evidentemente fue un maravilloso día
para convertirnos todos en superhéroes
qué quiere decir con esto porque nos
empeñamos tanto
en tener a los niños tan ocupados desde
que son tan pequeños
y si realmente yo lanzo una pregunta
todos los niños y niñas tienen tiempo
real para jugar
profe puedo jugar no ahora no podemos
primeras demás esta actividad y luego ya
si tenemos contrato jugamos
mamá puedo jugar
bueno hijo vamos a primero hacer esto
vamos a cenar y luego ya si no hace
tiempo jugamos papá puede jugar no y
hasta que no termine los deberes
hasta que no hayamos senado hasta que
nos haya escuchado el que haya puesto el
pijama luego si nos da tiempo antes
tiene una cama jugamos un ratito
una realidad
evidentemente la conciliación familiar
no ayuda porque siempre vivimos en una
sociedad de prisas
hay una mujer
y a mí me gusta mucho se llama teresa
avilés
pérez avilés
ha estado dedicándose toda su vida es
profesora de la universidad en eeuu y ha
estado toda su vida
investigando sobre esto dice que la
creatividad para ella es un estofado con
sus ingredientes
y uno de los más importantes es el fuego
ese fuego que cuece todos los
ingredientes a las especias para que
todos los sabores y todos los colores se
unan entre ellos
ese fuego representa la pasión
y esa pasión representa la motivación
intrínseca que nosotros tenemos a la
hora de hacer las cosas esa motivación
intrínseca que hace que hagamos lo que
nos gusta por el mero placer de hacerlo
y sin recibir ningún tipo de recompensa
aparte dice
en los momentos creativos nos
encontramos en cualquier momento de
nuestra vida en cualquier momento de
nuestra infancia
que tenemos que pararnos a reflexionar
ser flexibles y querer salir de nuestra
zona de confort de querer salir de esos
productos homogéneos de fábrica como yo
decía
después de este estofado
solamente me quedo con tres cosas que
dije en mi último libro el viaje cósmico
el saturnino
más arte más movimiento más fuego en
definitiva más creatividad
y sobre todo
y el mundo sería mucho más bonito si lo
viéramos desde los ojos de los niños
[Aplausos]